medical researchers have been looking  into a link between obesity and covit  they say it is a deadly combination and  it's a risk factor that affects more  than 40 percent of american adults  but there is some positive news the  cleveland clinic published a study that  found that those who lost weight through  weight loss surgeries had a 60 percent  lower risk of developing severe  complications from covid  we had  near 5000 patients with obesity who had  periapic surgery at the cleveland clinic  between 2004 and 2017  and we matched them carefully match them  with over 15 000 patients with obesity  who receive usual care  doctors hope increased studies like this  will increase awareness of the  importance surrounding obesity among  patients and those who care for them  with the health care providers and the  policy makers